what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we are finally getting some teases
for the X-Men in the MCU but not vague
teases we are actually getting specific
teases about specific characters that
could be coming sooner rather than later
and also let me clarify this we are
talking about new X-Men characters about
new Mutant characters coming to the MCU
not older Fox X-Men characters coming
from another universe or an older
Universe because both of which seem to
be happening which we'll talk about in
this video but I am specifically talking
about mutants in our actual MCU in the
earth 616 our main MCU timeline Universe
Marvel clearly has plans for mutants and
the X-Men and the MCU we've already seen
little teases in phase four Kamala Khan
although not a mutant in the comics has
been retconned in the MCU to indeed be a
mutant and then of course in Black
Panther wakanda forever we got Namor who
is a mutant in the comics and is
confirmed to be a mutant in the MCU and
not only did he say that he was a mutant
in the film but Kevin feige the
president of Marvel Studios also said
that he was indeed a mutant however
these aren't really the traditional
X-Men characters that we are used to
seeing and most fans really want a
reboot and a new X-Men team to start
forming in the MCU much like the
Avengers did starting with Iron Man well
thanks to a recent report from a Marvel
Studios producer it looks like we know
some of the first two X-Men coming to
the MCU and these two that have been
teased are storm and Bishop two really
great characters that I'm really looking
forward to seeing in the MCU and it does
kind of look like storm might be making
her debut in Black Panther 3. now those
of you who know Storm's relationship
with black panther know that this is
really really exciting it is a tiny bit
tricky based off of what has happened in
wakanda forever and the unfortunate
passing of Chadwick Boseman however the
story I think we're about to get in
Black Panther 3 should be pretty dang
amazing so let's dive into this report
from producer Nate Moore so producer
Nate Moore for Marvel Studios has been a
producer for Captain America the Winter
Soldier Captain America Civil War the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier series the
eternals Black Panther wakanda forever
and will be a producer for the new
Captain America movie coming new world
order so doing an interview with
deadline about Black Panther wakanda
forever and when asked about what other
black superheroes Nate Moore would like
to bring to the MCU he said and I quote
there's no secret the X-Men are coming
home if you talk storm and Bishop
they're two of the great characters in
that franchise and when asked about when
we could expect them he said we're early
early days on the reboot and we kind of
know this right now we kind of know that
phase seven is really when the X-Men are
going to start coming to the MCU for
real so it seems like black panther 3
should be one of the first movies of
phase 7 and this is going to be one of
the films that kicks off the X-Men
starting with hopefully storm based off
of what producer Nate Moore said now if
you're curious about Black Panther 3
well it's already been confirmed several
people from Marvel have already stated
they have ideas for the next movie and
of course the post-credits scene for
wakanda forever set up a future not just
for the franchise but specifically a new
black panther a new t'challa and Leticia
Wright in a recent interview has
basically said that they are already
working on black panther 3. when are we
going to get black panther 3 Greenwood
I think it's already in the works you
know we just had a terrific two years of
of bringing it out and just everybody
just coming together to support it we
need a little bit of a break we need to
regroup and Ryan needs to get back you
know into the lab so it's gonna take a
while but really excited for you guys to
see that this is really important for
the future of the X-Men and mutants and
the MCU the reason being is that storm
of course is an X-Men she is a mutant
and she has major ties to Black Panther
because she marries him if you're a
comic book fan you probably knew this
but for those of you who didn't know
this it's actually a really huge deal in
the comics everybody comes together for
their wedding The Watcher himself even
shows up makes an appearance is seen
which is a huge deal and watches them
get married that's how big of a deal
their marriage was now sadly they end up
getting a divorce eventually but the
reason that they get a divorce could
actually be one of the big Avengers
level movies that we will have been
eventually get in the MCU and that is
The Avengers versus the X-Men they get a
divorce because of the Avengers vs X-Men
storyline where Namor and the Phoenix 5
flood wakanda and basically destroy it
it's kind of what we saw in Black
Panther wakanda forever so basically
black panther sides with the Avengers
and storm sides with the X-Men and
eventually after the damage to wakanda
is done black panther decides to get a
divorce from auroro AKA storm so one
could see how black panther 3 could set
up Storm and t'challa the son of King
t'challa we know that the X-Men that are
going to be coming to the MCU are going
to be young they're going to be around
in the MCU for a very long time
hopefully 10 plus years so the new ones
coming in will be young and I'm assuming
there's going to be some sort of a time
Jump to where we see t'challa grow up
and this is basically Marvel studios's
way of saying that they kind of did
recast t'challa they just didn't do it
yet out of respect to Chadwick now as
far as X-Men and the MCU are concerned
like I mentioned we are actually going
to be seeing some older generations of
X-Men appear in our main Universe I
think most people know that this is
entirely possible thanks to Avengers
Secret Wars and thanks to the events of
Loki and Spider-Man no way home and
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness the Multiverse opens up
Limitless possibilities to see other
variants but there are two very
important things that fans have been
talking about recently that we
definitely need to discuss we've gotten
some reports from some insiders like
Grace Randolph stating that Avengers
Secret Wars is kind of going to be Kevin
feige's goodbye to the older X-Men for
those of you who may not know Kevin
feige started his Marvel career with the
first X-Men film he then went on to do
Spider-Man Daredevil the Hulk and many
many others until he eventually started
the MCU and now with the Multiverse
existing in the MCU and Avengers Secret
Wars being all about the Multiverse and
different variants he's going to be
bringing the old original X-Men to the
MCU in our main universe and here
they're going to fight alongside our
team our new Avengers team our new
Fantastic Four and all of the other
Heroes that are going to be fighting
against Kang and probably a lot of
different King variants as well this is
important to note because before this we
probably aren't going to get too many
new X-Men characters introduced we'll
probably get some teases of some new
characters much like they did with Miss
Marvel calling her a mutant and the same
for Namor we'll probably get a few of
those along the way then Kevin feige
will say goodbye to the original X-Men
and Secret Wars getting those characters
into the MCU which many of those actors
say that they wish they got a chance to
be a part of the MCU because remember it
didn't exist all the way back in 2000
the connected Cinematic Universe wasn't
a thing so now they get their wish
fulfilled they get to be a part of it
say goodbye but then Marvel basically
gets to kind of start over a little bit
with the universe and start fresh with a
new group of superheroes the X-Men and
our new Fantastic Four team so phase 7
is really going to be the phase of
mutants The Avengers might take the back
seat for just a little bit of course
they're not going to go away it still is
the MCU it's still a connected Cinematic
Universe you can't just say they're gone
but I do believe the focus is going to
shift to the X-Men and to the Fantastic
Four which would be a very fresh thing
for the MCU to do and clearly based off
of what Nate Morris said the X-Men are
in their early days of development over
at Marvel Studios right now which is
great because even though Avengers
Secret Wars is the next huge Avengers
in-game level event of course Marvel
Studios is looking even further past
that into the future of the MCU getting
our new X-Men team ready to make their
debut and it's looking like storm and
Bishop are going to be some of the first
X-Men new X-Men to enter the MCU so let
me know how excited you are about this
in the comments down below and also let
me know what other X-Men you would like
to see first enter the MCU when we get
our first new X-Men team please don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to stay up to date on the MCU if you
have Instagram and Twitter be sure to to
give us a follow and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf